this has been a real trying time for me
because to finally get to have a kid and
I don't even get to enjoy all the time
of watch and baby girl grow and and
going through all the different emotions
with my wife with Halle because because
I'm quarantined I'm stuck here at the
office
this whole pandemic hitting at the same
time that she's right when she's about
to deliver it's just been real
frustrating okay um matt has been on
quarantine for two weeks it's a hard
time we miss each other
I'm 37 weeks pregnant
and I think that's why I'm super
protective about myself and a baby the
current situation in the world is
definitely a scary a little bit and I
don't want to be worried that much i I
just want to trust that everything will
be good I tried to get rid of these
thoughts and just stay positive
okay this is just a crazy world we're
living in nowadays wipe off the car
again real quick make sure I didn't
bring in anything hopefully I'm going
home I'm gonna have to call her find out
[Music]